foreign
shop
I'm delighted to be here this evening to
present this year's Sutherlands
leadership award at the European
commission president Ursula vondeline
who was accepting it on behalf of the
European Union
it is fitting that this award recognizes
the extraordinary contribution of the
late Peter Sutherland with the support
and participation of Peter's family
Peter's work at European union and
international level
including as European Union commissioner
and as director general of the WTO made
a real impact and he has left a legacy
of outstanding public service
having met Peter on many occasions I was
always struck that withstanding his
great achievements his his commitment
ongoing commitment to a better world and
a better place for people his concern to
improve the situation he fundamentally
believes in a multilateral rules-based
order and he was a powerful advocate for
free trade and Ireland owes him a great
debt of gratitude but I think also in
terms of the European context he was a
leader at the European level and that
Global level also to break down barriers
to facilitate
um free trade and it's a great privilege
for me to be here this evening in the
context of this award that recognizes an
outstanding Irish man and we say to his
family we will always remember him for
his loyal service to his country and you
have every right to be proud of that
rich Legacy
this award is particularly timely as we
approach the 50th anniversary of
Ireland's formal accession today in
European communities on the 1st of
January
and it was just over 50 years ago on the
10th of May 1972 that the Irish people
voted by an overwhelming majority to
join what has now become the European
Union
now as I was 12 years of age at the time
I remember it very well
it half well but of course one of the
reasons it sticks in our memory is a
corkman jack Lynch was leading the
charge in respect to the referendum and
itself and in doing so we were conscious
even as young people that this was a
major consequential decision one of the
most significant consequential decision
ever made by the Irish people in the
history of our state
and the generations growing up since
then and since our accession have seen
opportunities on the scale perhaps
unimaginable
to their predecessors and to that 12
year old back in 1972.
and our EU membership during this time
has also played a vital role in our
journey towards peace and Reconciliation
on this island
and those who were convinced that
Ireland's future lay in Europe did show
the courage to imagine in New Ireland
and a more confident and optimistic
future
then t-shirt Jack Lynch I think
described it at the time as at its core
the ideal and I quote of a vital force
for peace in the world and the Never
increasing contribution to the economic
and social progress of developing
nations
I'm sure you will all agree that five
decades since our accession the five
decades since our accession have been
defined by close reciprocal cooperation
with our European partners
the European Union has contributed
significantly to our economic and social
development and to shaping Ireland's
emergence as a modern open society and
economy and there is much to celebrate
and I encourage all of you here this
evening to consider your own initiatives
to Mark the significant anniversary
unfortunately the appalling events
unfolding in Ukraine give those words
ordered by Jack Lynch over 50 years ago
poignant significance today
Ireland remains clear
in our political support for Ukraine
both in terms of supporting tough
sanctions on Russia but also in
supporting and setting UK in its
Ukraine's path towards European union
membership
the government there in Ukraine is
firmly committed despite the awful
circumstances to meet the high bar
required for accession to the European
Union
I'm delighted that we're joined this
evening by Ukrainian Ambassador Larissa
and again I say to you and to your
people that you are part of the European
family and I have consistently advocated
that a free Sovereign and Democratic
Ukraine belongs to the European Union
[Applause]
the people of Ukraine face a long and
very difficult winter as temperatures
drop and as Russia's Relentless attacks
on vital civilian infrastructure
continue
the average people have been moved by
the exceptional leadership shown by
President zielinski which I would like
to acknowledge here tonight
the people of Ireland will continue to
stand shoulder to shoulder with the
people of Ukraine
I had the opportunity earlier to commend
president vonderlane both in person and
at this afternoon's joint sitting of the
houses of the Iraqis for her very
sure-footed and strong leadership in
response to this horrific War
president vonderlane's leadership was
also evident throughout covid-19 and the
pandemic
which confronted the European Union and
its member states with an immense
challenge in an area where the Union's
competence is limited or appeared to be
limited at the onset of the pandemic
itself
and through president Wonderland's
leadership to commission's role was
Central to The Accelerated development
manufacturing and deployment of safe and
effective vaccines and to the historic
two trillion Euro budgetary package
agreed by European union leaders in July
of 2020. and that will be no doubt that
president vondrian has played a very
significant role in our Collective
demonstration that in the most testing
of times European union leaders can work
together and find solutions that deliver
for its citizens
and at a time when democracy is under
pressure in many parts of the world we
also need to renew and strengthen our
Partnerships with key allies not least
United States and the United Kingdom
so you have been to the fore in working
to strengthen the vital transatlantic
relationship
and the solidarity you and the
commission have shown with Ireland
throughout brexit and that's shown by a
wider European Union family is greatly
appreciated
I
[Applause]
on a person level I wore I genuinely
appreciate the many personal contacts
and engagements that we have had
particularly in relation to pandemic
vaccines but also in terms of the war
um on Ukraine and having witnessed and
the evolution of the European Union
during different times in government
mucho various I have said in terms of
your response and your leadership I
doubt would have been possible 20 years
ago or 10 years ago
but when the going gets tough
you rise to the occasion and I would say
that you have risen spectacularly to the
occasion given the challenges that have
come your way and your contribution as
president of the European commission has
been truly immense and is my great
pleasure and honor to invite you to
accept accept on behalf of the European
Union this year is Sutherland leadership
award
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
t-shock Martin Dia Michal Mr Highland
members of the Sutherland family
distinguished guests
it is such an honor
to accept this award on behalf of the
European Union and of course on behalf
of the European citizens and on behalf
of the European citizens of Ireland
you are about to celebrate indeed your
50th anniversary to the in the European
Union next year and I want to say from
the bottom of my heart congratulations
what an achievement
[Applause]
I know the Irish people you are proud
Europeans but let me tell you Europe is
even prouder that we can call you family
for the story of Ireland in the European
Union inspired so much hope especially
at a time when War has sadly returned to
our continent
the story of Ireland you know it all is
a story of reconciliation
of peace and of progress
and perhaps no one better embodies these
qualities than Peter Sutherland
Peter Sutherland
was a man of faith
a man with a profound sense of civic
responsibility
he became Ireland's youngest attorney
general at the height of the troubles
and his belief in the rule of law and
fairness
was profound
as Islands European commissioner he
never forgot
what he had learned in Ireland
Peter Sutherland was one of the
architects of the single Market well you
all know it one of the greatest economic
achievements of our European union today
this is where the prosperity comes from
because we all know we are much more
than just 27 member states we are an
economic Powerhouse and this single
Market is the foundation of our wealth
it's Peter Sutherland who was one of the
Architects and many thanks again for him
for having done and achieved all that
he was especially proud of having
launched the Erasmus program
because it's about youth
and of course you know he knew that
young people if they travel across the
European Union if they have their first
experience when studying abroad that
they will fall in love with the country
they are in and they will be the best
ambassadors for the rest of their life
for this country and for the European
ideas
and therefore Erasmus has up to today
offered over 65 000 Irish students and
teachers life-changing experiences and
actually more than over 13 million
people overall
it has enriched all of them and deep and
personal and cultural bonds across our
Union
and for Peter Sutherland
greater integration of people and idea
reaching out to others
was a way to check the national
nationalistic excesses that has
disfigured the continent's recent story
history
excesses that in his own words he had
seen too much
of it in his own country
and when Ireland joined the European
Union the conflict in Northern in
Northern Ireland showed few signs of
ending
but European integration played a vital
role in overcoming the hard border and
thus helped pave the way to the of the
road to reconciliation
we Europeans know by experience
that the essence of this Union
is to Reach Out Among the people for
peace and for progress
and that's that's my dear friends here
tonight let me reassure you again and
let me promise to you again
Ireland can always count on the European
Union to defend the peace process
Ireland can always count on the European
Union to stand by The Good Friday
agreement
and Ireland can always count on the
European Union to make sure that there
will be no hard border again on the
island of Ireland
[Applause]
since joining the European family Irish
Society has truly blossomed
let me give you figures
in 1973 Ireland's GDP per head was a
around half the average half the average
of the member states
today
the GDP of Ireland per capita is double
than the average of the European Union
in just 50 years
this is a remarkable achievement
and it is also thanks to the Ingenuity
of the Irish people and their
enthusiastic use of freedoms
freedoms to study to work trade and
travel across the European Union
freedoms backed by rules-based order
that was so dear to Peter Sutherland
and indeed today these rules and rights
are threatened
the right to be a free
and Democratic Nation
and the right to have
your own decision
how you want to have your own future
Russia's warned Ukraine is a direct
attack on these rights
Russia has the declared objective to
bring down a legitimate government
and establish rule from Moscow
it is merciless
in its attempt to terrorize the
Ukrainian people but deliberately
targeting civilian infrastructure
cutting off children women men young and
old from water heating and electricity
and Winters coming
this is a blatant breach of humanitarian
law and the U.N Charter and this is why
we stand by Ukraine as long as it takes
Ukraine can rely on us and our support
[Applause]
because we all also very clearly feel in
this historical moment
yes Russia's war is about Ukraine but it
is not only about Ukraine
and that is why we know that Ukraine is
fighting for more and for us
because Russia's war is about
autocracies
against democracies
it is about the question will there be
the right of Might
or the rule of law
will there be new walls and trenches
or peaceful coexistence and open
cooperation between people and countries
and first Europeans the choice is clear
we stand up for this fight that Ukraine
is fighting for us we stand at the side
of open Democratic Societies in Europe
and Beyond
for this Europe has to remain strong in
itself
and this is why we are working hard to
increase the resilience of our Union we
are defending the rule of law outside
the European Union as well as insight
we are breaking through free from
Russia's blackmail of fossil fuels we're
investing on renewable energy like never
before
because we want to take responsibility
for future Generations by implementing
our European green deal it's for our
children that we are doing that our new
growth strategy it's their future that
will be decided now it's worth fighting
for it
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
we want Europe
to be a force for progress and for good
and for peace this is our mission
this was Peter Sutherland's mission
and thanks to individuals like him
but also thanks to all the European
citizens of Ireland
I am confident
that we will progress being a Force for
good
being a force for peace you stand for
what you believe
and you never take Freedom or peace for
granted because you know how fragile and
how precious it is therefore long live
our passion for peace long live our
passion for Freedom Long Live Ireland
long-lived Europe thank you so much
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
before we
[Applause]
before we leave the stage we have a
small token of appreciation for the
president so somebody's going to run
with a gift for me uh here in a second
um this year is a a year of Milestones
uh for Ireland
um
we mentioned the upcoming 50th
anniversary of our accession to European
Union uh it is of course our Centenary
of our free state
um
very importantly it is also the
Centenary Century of Ulysses
and we have a gift for president for the
line which I think would be uh quite
important you may know that James Joyce
of course was the author of udice and
but in Ulysses he reminds us of
important line
he says that we are tomorrow
some future day will be established
today and it is only fitting thank you
it's only fitting that the EU plays such
a role today in creating a better
tomorrow for all of us together so
president vondoline thank you for being
with us tonight on behalf of all of us
it's the little gift first edition by
the way
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah and go first
see you later